pas encore dîner de la mode c'est une
des scènes imaginées par ses élèves de
ce1
ce chat s'interroge sur un animal
étrange un lamantin qui jadis existait
dans les eaux martiniquaise
une curiosité qui est le fil conducteur
de ce court métrage nous avons jamais eu
l'occasion de le voir même cinéma on
n'en voit pas et on vous l'a le faire
revenir
depuis trois ans cette classe
s'intéressent à la production
audiovisuelle
l'association boule calicots lui donne
un soutien logistique et dit orianne
cette année élèves et enseignants ont
fait le choix d'une fiction
ce projet rentre et donc dans le projet
d'école
donc il nous permet de connaître la
ville du lamentin
donc ce sont des petits laventinois
reconnaître l'origine du nom de la
commune connaître les différents lieux
qu'il y ait dans la commune dont le
centre culturel est la bibliothèque le
marché autres classes et autres
réalisations
ces élèves ont fait le choix d'un
documentaire autour de ce jardin
réalisés par leurs soins
un support images qui entrent également
dans le projet de classe et ce sont les
élèves qui en parlent le mieux
la platé des papayes
radi du plantier du tas on a vu eni on a
vu auparavant un ce colon poigne ce que
tu as appris que i les plaintes ont
besoin de soleil
et dans un projet d'école qui portent
visiblement beaucoup de fruits aux
preuves dans cette autre classe de ce1
ce film est tout simplement le leur
[Musique]
ainsi minutes
imaginez tournée interprété et réalisé
par toute la classe travail de cinq mois
qu'ils découvrent avec bonheur
je voulais être inspectés que tu vas
aimer jouer le rôle de jardinier tue le
jeu plutôt très bien parce que tu as
aimé être acteur qui a retenu que les
bêtes
enfin il faut pas qu'il faut pas avoir
de pesticides dans la terme
on a l'occasion à travers ce projet
d'aborder
des notions en production d'écrits en
lecture en langage oral également
énormément et ça permet surtout aux
élèves de s'investir à fond dans leur
apprentissage et surtout de comprendre
pourquoi ils doivent faire des efforts
et s'investir dans leur apprentissage
parce qu'à la fin est un produit fini
une satisfaction partagée et peut-être
des vocations dans la production
audiovisuelle